les enquêteurs tiennent peut être une
piste dans la sphère du tueur des
ardennes responsable de la mort de deux
adolescentes ces dernières années en
france est 61 ans a en effet été arrêté
en belgique jeudi dernier après
l'enlèvement manqué d'une fillette de 13
ans les modes opératoires semble en
effet similaire à google maps qui est
cyril duponchel sur place un fait divers
sordide en belgique et c'est une enquête
à tiroirs qui démarre jeudi ce forestier
français expatriés est arrêté chez lui
en belgique accusée d'avoir enlevé et
tenté d'abuser d'une adolescente de 12
ans la jeune fille qui est parvenu à
s'échapper va livrer un précieux récit à
la police l'homme l'a persuadée de
monter dans son fourgon prétextant
chercher une adresse
l'agression a été commise en plein jour
et par ruse ce mode opératoire alerte
les enquêteurs belges
le scénario apparemment très rôdée
rappel des hypothèses émises dans deux
autres dossiers
la disparition de céline saison
retrouvées mortes en juillet 2000 dans
les ardennes belges et celle de mananya
tom fonds 13 ans dont le corps sera
découvert en mars 2002 également dans un
bois près de la frontière
les autorités françaises ont pris
contact et elles vont travailler de
coopération avec les autorités belges
pour justement pour voir si des indices
ne peuvent pas être décelées dans
différents dossiers
officiellement le rapprochement entre
les trois affaires n'est pas fait brice
longue signé et le beau-père de mananya
le srpj de reims l'a informé de cette
nouvelle piste avec la prudence qui
s'impose
eva côté on s'est trouvé très soulagé et
puis d'un autre côté il faut quand même
se rendre à l'évidence on a il faut pas
trop se faire d'illusions je veux dire
rien n'est prouvé on a aucune preuve
aucune certitude et
il va falloir certainement et du temps
et de la patience ont encore une fois
désormais belges et français travaillent
ensemble grâce à deux commissions
rogatoires internationales
le domicile du forestier a été
perquisitionné par la police belge des
prélèvements biologiques vont être
effectués dans son fourgon
l'homme a déjà été condamné pour viol
dans les années 80 un passé tumultueux
que les enquêteurs français vont te
tenter de retracer à la recherche des
secrets que les corps décomposés de
céline et de mananya n'ont pas pu
entièrement livre la qualité judiciaire
je vous le disais une semaine après la
fin du procès dutroux la belgique voit
donc se profiler une nouvelle affaire
effroyable de tueur en série la belgique
mais aussi la france puisque l'homme qui
est passé aux aveux et français michel
fourniret 62 ans il est détenu depuis un
an par la justice belge
il a avoué le meurtre de six enfants et
adolescentes des deux côtés de la
frontière c'est son épouse qui est
passée aux aveux la première
jérôme soûlard avec yann fronty à liège
c'est peut-être le visage d'un nouveau
tueur en série que la belgique vient de
découvrir aujourd'hui michel fourniret
62 ans un français arrêté il ya tout
juste un an après l'enlèvement raté
d'une fille est un délinquant sexuel
déjà condamné dénoncé cette semaine par
sa femme
elle accuse de neuf meurtres il en
reconnaît six pour l'instant prudente
la justice belge organise aujourd'hui
une conférence de presse
beaucoup d'éléments restent à vérifier
mais le profil du prévenu semble établi
ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que
le mobile est d'ordre sexuel donc c'est
une personne qui déclare elle-même
qu'elle va à la chasse
qu'elle essaye de trouver des jeunes
filles vierges c'est un peu cela son son
fantasme et qu'après un jour deux jours
il ne sait plus qu'en faire et à ce
moment là et bien ils les tuent les
étrangle généralement et les éliminant
les enterrant devant les enquêteurs
fourniret a reconnu les meurtres
d'isabelle la ville ici à l'image
disparu à auxerre en 87 celui de jeanne
marie 12 ans disparue en 89 en belgique
la petite elizabeth briché disparu en 89
serait elle aussi une victime avoué du
français mais le père d'elizabeth reste
prudent il souhaite des preuves
formelles
j'attends confirmation
du procureur de roi parce que parce que
parce que moi je n'avance pas les choses
comme ça la légère 30 j'en ai toujours
su j'aurais dessus dans les jours qui
viennent les enquêteurs vont donc
travailler sur une dizaine de dossiers
criminels des disparitions non élucidés
8 côté français une ou deux pour la
belgique
quant à l'ancien domicile du délinquant
sexuel le château de s'auto près de
sedan
il devrait être fouillée de fond en
comble les recherches pourrait commencer
dès jeudi
voici le château du forestier des
ardennes une superbe bâtisse caché au
milieu d'un bois épais à la frontière
franco belge
un manoir qu'il aurait acheté après
avoir dérobé le magot de l'un de ses
compagnons de prison
un malfaiteur proche des terroristes
d'action directe dont il aurait
assassiné la femme pour récupérer
l'argent dans la région on se souvient
d'un homme peu bavard discret mais qui
utilisait souvent un tracto pelle pour
creuser des tranchées fossé mais il
avait pu engranger d'un kilomètre lui et
avec une drogue poubelles deux poisons
moyennement les boucles épaules des
doutes des questions le personnage n'a
livré qu'une partie de sa sombre
personnalité certains la découvre
brutalement depuis hier c'est le cas de
jocelyne et gérard pendant des années
ils ont côtoyé ce tueur présumé sans se
douter de rien michel fourniret a même
gardé plusieurs fois leurs jeunes
enfants
on n'a jamais rien remarqué
y'a aucun aucun détail qui nous a fait
soupçonner quoi que ce soit rien du tout
au contraire
au contraire c'est même un gars qui
dégageait une certaine intelligence qui
dégageait nous un certain caractère
c'est un gars qui était propre toujours
bien habillé courageux bosseur jamais on
aurait pu penser un truc pareil jamais
jamais jamais jamais
à tel point qu'il l'avait même invité à
la communion de leur fils qu'ils avaient
filmé à l'époque on distingue ici michel
fourniret et sa femme ce soir les
fouilles n'ont pas encore commencé
autour du château mais des moyens lourds
dont des véhicules militaires du génie
sont déjà arrivés à proximité
les enquêteurs n'attendent plus que le
feu vert des deux juges d'instruction
belge et français pour commencer leur
macabre recherche quatre nouvelles mises
en examen pour michel fourniret il
s'agit vous le savez de ce tueur en
série auquel on impute cette meurtre
jusqu'à présent seule la justice belge
l'avait inculpé
les juges français ont fait le
déplacement en belgique pour
l'interroger et entamer les poursuites
amaury guibert guillaume michel haute
protection autour de michel fourniret
dans les couloirs du palais de justice
de dinan l'homme semble impassible que
la semaine est décisive
plus de six mois après les aveux les
premières mises en examen dans ce
dossier pour le tueur en série présumé
et dans quatre pour sa femme monique
olivier loin de cette agitation
judiciaire les la ville espère toujours
savoir une chose où repose le corps
d'isabelle leur fille tuée en décembre
1987 près d'auxerre par michel fourniret
il avoué le crime mais dit ne plus se
souvenir où il enterrait la jeune fille
de l'enquêté la ville ne savent pourtant
presque rien depuis que tous les
dossiers ont été centralisés à
charleville mézières
je n'ai plus aucun contact et je ne sais
plus ce qui se passe plus rien donc si
vous voulez c'est sûr qu'on peut être en
colère chaque fois que l'afer a été
relancée d'une façon ou d'une autre au
bout de quelques mois le silence est
retombé et si b c'est très difficile à
gérer
les victimes ne sont pas oubliés répond
le procureur de charleville mézières qui
promet de ne pas perdre de temps
je me suis engagé et nous nous sommes
engagés en france à juger fourniret et
olivier dans un délai extrêmement court
compte tenu du non et la complexité des
dossiers c'est à dire un délai de 18
mois
les yeux masqués comme le veut la
procédure belge pour les détenus
dangereux
michel fourniret regagné sa prison la
prochaine étape c'est une extradition
vers la france
mais pas avant quelques mois
le tueur en série michel fourniret est
accusé d'être l'auteur de plusieurs
nouveaux meurtres en belgique c'est en
tout cas ce qu'a affirmé son épouse
devant un juge d'instruction belge
amaury guibert on la disait soumises
réservés aujourd'hui monique olivier
n'en finit plus de passer aux aveux de
nouveaux meurtres qu'elle impute à son
mari michel fourniret
trois jeunes filles selon des sources
policières sis selon des sources
judiciaires en belgique des assassinats
qui se serait produit alors que le
couple vivait ici à sart-custinne en
belgique une vie sans histoire dans
cette maison avec leur fils certaines
des victimes seraient d'ailleurs des
jeunes filles au pair recruté pour
s'occuper de l'enfant
ces déclarations vont venir grossir le
lourd dossier d'instruction du juge
belge
au fil des auditions des enquêtes côté
belge ou français
la liste des victimes s'allonge et donne
le vertige du meurtre d'isabelle la
ville en 87 à celui de mananya tum pong
en 2001 michel fourniret pourrait
maintenant avoir commis 20 meurtres mais
quel crédit accorder aux déclarations de
sa femme beaucoup plus prolixe mais pas
forcément plus précise elle ne donne
aucun nom
les enquêteurs n'ont trouvé aucun corps
le tueur en série lui n'a reconnu
jusqu'ici que huit assassinats
c'est l'un des plus redoutables tueurs
en série de ces dernières années michel
fourniret a quitté sa prison en belgique
aujourd'hui pour être remis aux
autorités judiciaires françaises
michel fourniret à 63 ans il est
soupçonné des meurtres de 13 jeunes
filles amaury guibert sylvain gauthier
deux voitures blindées banalisée arrive
en trombe de bruxelles il est 11h sur un
poste frontière belge un dispositif
policier conséquent est en place pour
accueillir michel fourniret
masques sur les yeux le tueur en série
présumé et emmenés à l'intérieur l'un
des magistrats belges des français
règlent les derniers détails de la
procédure d'extradition
un passage de témoin attendu depuis
plusieurs mois j'ai commis aussi bien
mais ce fonds serait que le dossier qui
le concerne une heure et demie plus tard
michel fourniret arrive au palais de
justice de charleville mézières des
gendarmes l'escort jusqu'au bureau du
juge d'instruction
derrière il en faut une dizaine d'autres
pour apporter la partie belge du
volumineux dossier de procédure
le tueur en série présumé sera jugé pour
sept meurtres et trois agressions sans
doute avant la fin de l'année je
souhaite que ce procès soit le plus
rapide possible et je souhaite tout
autant que ce procès repose sur un
dossier qui soit le plus étoffée
possible qui soit le plus complet
on ne puisse pas reprocher à la justice
d'avoir été trop trop vite un dossier
bâclé pour un procès rapide c'est la
crainte des avocats de michel fourniret
l'instruction suivra son cours et la
précipitation n'est pas une vertu
majeure en matière judiciaire
en milieu d'après midi michel fourniret
a été emmené vers la prison de châlons
en champagne
là seules dans la région à pouvoir
accueillir les détenus considérés comme
dangereux
y at il un lien entre la disparition
d'estelle mouzin en janvier 2003 et le
tueur en série michel fourniret
rien n'est moins sûr mais rien ne doit
être laissé au hasard et si aucun
élément pour l'instant ne permette de le
faire suspecter
l'avocat du père d'estelle a demandé au
juge une copie d'une cassette retrouver
chez fournirait franck gêne au zoo
mathias barrois michel fourniret déjà
accusé de sept meurtres est il impliqué
dans l'enlèvement d'estelle mouzin la
petite estelle a disparu depuis près de
quatre ans et les enquêteurs ne
disposent d'aucune piste sérieuse mais
depuis deux jours une cassette vidéo
bien relancé la piste fourniret une
cassette d'un reportage sur estelle
retrouvé à son domicile il ya plusieurs
années
dans le même lot un autre reportage sur
une autre cassette
celui ci concerne elisabeth briché
michel fourniret a reconnu l'avoir tuée
le 20 décembre 80 une chose est sûre la
cassette sur estelle n'a jamais été
transmise aux enquêteurs chargés de son
enlèvement
maintenant qu'on connaît mieux son
emploi du temps qu'on sait que dans
cette période de janvier on n'a pas été
expressément identifié ce qu'il faisait
et qu'il a dit à son frère qu'il était
en voyage à ce moment là je crois qu'il
faut renforcer les recherches pour vous
dire c'est lui ou fermer cette porte
curiosité morbide ou simple coïncidence
michel fourniret disposerait d'un alibi
solide un coup de téléphone passé à son
fils le jour de l'enlèvement
depuis son domicile son fils qui n'a pas
vu depuis plusieurs années ne se
rappelle pas de cet appel de son père
c'est quand même bizarre il ne voit pas
son père pendant très longtemps il
aurait appelé ce soir là et son fils ne
se rappelle pas deuxièmement on ne sait
pas qui a passé ce cet appel chez michel
fourniret il ya monique olivier sa femme
il ya un autre de ses fils ces éléments
pourrait donc relancer les
investigations
michel fourniret lui a toujours nié
toute implication dans l'enlèvement
l'ouverture à charleville mézières du
procès de michel fourniret
les familles des victimes redoutent est
une provocation ça n'a pas manqué
l'accusé est resté muet dans une mise en
scène bien étudié fixant ses conditions
pour s'exprimer dans un document
transmis à la cour il se décrit comme un
être mauvais et dénué de tout sentiment
humain sur place amaury guibert mathias
secondes il avait laissé planer le doute
mais michel fourniret a finalement
accepté de venir à l'ouverture de son
procès une image furtive puis une chaise
vide dans le box le tueur en série
présumé refuse d'être filmé quand il
fera son entrée sa femme monique olivier
ne lui adressera pas un regard
face à eux les familles de victimes elle
attendait cette confrontation depuis
parfois plus de 20 ans il m'a fait que
c'est pendant quelques secondes
et je vous assure je vais pas baisser
les yeux mais je n'écoute que
[Musique]
pieds froids sept meurtres trois
agressions la litanie des crimes
reprochés à michel fourniret et à sa
femme résonne dans la salle d'audience
pour les parties civiles la lecture de
l'ordonnancé de mise en accusation est
une épreuve
une de plus il est vrai que c'est
toujours délicat et difficile d'entendre
ces monstruosités que
qu'il a réalisé quoi sans huis clos
bouche cousue avait pourtant menacé
michel fourniret avec ce papier brandi à
l'ouverture de l'audience
une exigence détaillé dans cette lettre
une bouffonnerie pour les parties
civiles
ce que conteste la défense ne pense pas
qu une bouffonnerie de la part de
monsieur pour nouvelle pour lui c'est
quelque chose de très sérieux
ils attachent de l'importance
des détails des procédures des choses
comme ça mais bon c'est son et en
quittant le palais de justice
michel fourniret a de nouveau laissé
planer le doute lui seul sait s'il sera
présent demain dans le box des accusés
l'actualité judiciaire encore avec la
suite du procès fourniret
le tueur en série présumé est brièvement
sorti de son mutisme
aujourd'hui et de façon plutôt
inattendue c'est un détail qu'il a fait
réagir ils s'accusent lui même d'être un
monstre
amaury guibert mathias secondes il avait
jusqu'ici affiché un mutisme classant
michel fourniret a montré aujourd'hui
une autre facette de sa personnalité
la colère en fin d'audience l'avocat
général évoque un détail quand l'accusé
le tance je ne peux pas laisser passer
une erreur grossière dit il eh bien vous
parler maintenant lui répond l'avocat
général michel fourniret hausse la voix
je ne parle pas je gueule et sur le même
ton je n'ai jamais caché que j'étais un
monstre
s'ils parlaient c'est hurler je suis un
effectivement il a beaucoup parlé mais
il a repris immédiatement l'attitude qui
est la sienne depuis le début du procès
de nouveau le mutisme mais pour les
parties civiles
un pas a été franchi celle ci en tous
les cas qu'il est extrêmement
désagréable pour lui
d'entendre parler de la troisième
personne sans pouvoir répondre dans
l'après midi la cour a examiné le
véhicule de michel fourniret sur le
parking du palais de justice
cette partie était à huis clos une des
exigences de l'accusé alors il a bien
voulu répondre en question tentant ainsi
une nouvelle fois de maîtriser le cours
de son procès autre fait marquant de
cette journée son épouse et complice
présumé monique olivier a exprimé des
regrets sans parvenir à expliquer sa
passivité j'étais très seul à l'époque
j'étais sous influence je regrette tout
ce qui a été fait fin de citation
l'air de famille est évident pourtant le
frère de michel fourniret a changé de
nom pour sa propre réputation
je suis écartelé dit il je n'ai pas
envie de défendre un assassin d'enfants
mais je n'ai pas le droit d'attaquer mon
frère c'est un mégalomane tout son
succès et baser sur le bluff
il agit par domination et puis soudain
le vieil homme se tourne vers les
victimes
je compatis à votre douleur je pense à
vous si vous avez besoin de quelque
chose je serai toujours là l'instant est
inattendu presque magique on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya quand même un peu d'humanité à
dans la famille
c'est le premier témoin qui se tournent
vers nous pour pour un peu nous exprimer
un peu et bien sa compassion et certains
d'entre vous nous ont même dit merci
oui c'est effectivement j'entends du
sommet et j'ai la même une dame qui peut
rien depuis un mois magistrats et
avocats tentent de faire craquer
fournirait en vain et c'est la fille
d'un de ses employeurs qui parvient tu
me fais honte pour papa dis ce que tu as
sur le coeur fait le pour moi
michel fourniret secoué trouble et fond
en larmes l'orgueilleux que je suis ne
te répondra pas on ne demande pas pardon
pour ce qui est impardonnable consentent
à dire fournir et ils auraient
extrêmement surprenant que le chef
fournirai
s'écroule en pleurant et en demandant
pardon c'est pas sûr c'est qu'ils
pleurent rient pleurent sur lui michel
fourniret qui refuse toujours de se
livrer en public
monique olivier qui hier évoque du bout
des lèvres une vie monotone sans amour
une vie de soumission face à eux sur le
banc des parties civiles les familles
des dix victimes
elle écoute courageusement il ya des
souffrances qui ne se compare pas on en
vient à l'actualité judiciaire le procès
de michel fourniret et de monique
olivier touche à sa fin c'était
aujourd'hui l'heure du réquisitoire le
procureur a donc demandé la perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté
incompressible contre le tueur en série
présumé perpétuité également à
l'encontre de son épouse avec une peine
de sûreté de trente ans sur place daniel
verdes haillan bruno vignais depuis cinq
ans l'avocat général porte ce dossier à
bout de bras je n'en peux plus de ces
horreurs dit francis nachbar alors ce
sont des mots que l'on entend rarement
dans la bouche d'un magistrat keaton aux
assises vous êtes des monstres des faits
les pauvres malades à gerber fournirait
à gerber monique olivier mais surprise
avocat général redistribue les rôles il
y a le pitoyable petit fourniret et à
côté la sorcière l'égérie la muse du
crime sans elle dit le magistrat
rien n'aurait été possible l'avocat de
monique olivier a l'impression qu'on a
changé de procès
c'est un réquisitoire contre monique
olivier et qui dédouanent michel
fourniret
c'est tout ce qui en dit c'est pas
vraiment une surprise pour nous puisque
on ne sait fourniret
il ya strictement aucune discussion est
donc tout l'effort a été axée sur
monique olivier perpétuité réelle sans
remise de peine possible requise contre
fournirait à perpétuité avec période de
sûreté de 30 ans contre son épouse
le maximum prévu par la loi la moindre
des choses selon les parties civiles
en face de 7,8 mort de viols etc
on ne peut rien mettre en face on pourra
mettre toutes les peine qu'on veut ça
n'atténuera jamais lu de cinq heures de
réquisitoire durant lesquelles les deux
accusés ont offert des visage de marbre
michel fourniret a fermé les yeux sans
broncher monique olivier a baissé la
tête
tentant de se faire oublier après deux
mois de débats
le rideau est donc tombé cet après midi
sur le procès fourniret
sans surprise la cour d'assises a suivi
les réquisitions de l'avocat général
à 66 ans le tueur en série ne devrait
plus quitté la prison jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie sur place à charleville mézières
dominique verdeilhan bruno vignais une
nuit à la caserne 24 heures de délibéré
les jurés viennent de répondre aux 75
questions
un verdict tant attendu que tout le
monde devine davance au même moment les
deux accusés arrive au palais ils ne se
font aucune illusion sur le verdict
dehors c'est la cohue médiatique et
populaire
on veut les voir pour la dernière fois
michel fourniret et monique olivier
condamnés à la perpétuité lynx en
aménagement de peine
l'autre à une période de sûreté de 28
ans un verdict qui apaise les parents
des victimes
après huit semaines de procès
on avait peur qu'elle est qu'elle est
moins bon elle peut encore faire appel
mais on n'y croit pas trop
et ils ne feront plus mal à personne
c'est surtout ça qui est important
il faut s'arrêter de poser des questions
parce qu'on en sait suffisamment et je
pense que la douleur on l'a partagée
voilà stop il faut faut tirer un peu de
riz dont un face à face tendu de deux
mois qui a permis aussi aux victimes
survivantes de fourniret de se
déculpabiliser et j'ai vraiment envie de
continuer de montrer qu'à que son feu et
que la vie continue et qui est encore
plein de belles choses
un verdict qui définit les rôles dans
ces crimes à quatre mains michel
fourniret est auteure principale monique
olivier sa complice monique olivier
c'est un diable c'est une criminelle
sans être humain et elle est défendable
et en tout cas il me semble que ça ça a
été entendu un procès qui s'achève par
un voeu du président de la cour
d'assises qu'il n'y ait pas d'appel afin
dit-il que chacun puisse se retrouver
dans le silence et l'apaisement mais
pour certaines victimes la justice les a
fait patienter pendant 21 ans
peut-on établir un lien entre michel
fourniret condamné à perpétuité pour le
meurtre de plusieurs jeunes filles et la
disparition d'estelle mouzin il y a
maintenant sept ans à guermantes les
parents de la fillette demande à la
justice d'examiner des élément provenant
du dossier du tueur en série des scellés
jamais exploité edouard da costa
philippe castel est ce que la route
d'estelle mouzin a croisé le 9 janvier
2003 celle de michel fourniret
cette question reste sans réponse malgré
les dénégations du tueur en série
l'avocat du père de la fillette didier
seban voudrait bien que la justice sans
la sueur et notamment parce qu'il ya des
éléments troublants
ceci est le bulletin de signalement de
la disparition d'estelle
il y est indiqué que la fillette était
chaussée de bottes blanches à lacets et
équipés de gants de ski noir dans les
scellés qui ont été saisis au domicile
de michel fourniret
on retrouve des morceaux de lacets
blancs et des gants polaire noire des
éléments que l'avocat demande
aujourd'hui être analysées par la
justice le juge d'instruction ne
laissera pas sans réponse cette
initiative mais il faut éviter tout
emballement prématuré éviter
l'emballement car malgré des recherches
déjà menées aucune preuve de
l'implication de michel fourniret n'est
encore apparue juste des coïncidences
comme la voiture signalée suspects dans
la disparition d'estelle
elle est identique à celle que michel
fourniret a acheté au long de monique
olivier
deux mois avant la disparition d'estelle
on sait aussi que michel fourniret
à séjourner en 87 à gournay à 3 minutes
exactement du domicile d'estelle mouzin
il connaît c'est donc bien la région
tout cela n'en fait pas pour autant la
sasa de la fillette mais le père
d'estelle voudrais que tout ce qui a été
retrouvé dans la maison de fournir en
belgique soit en femmes alizé et que les
dizaines de cheveux prélevés soient
comparés à l'adn des stand
[Musique]